[Music]  My dear Belle your soul a head of your  time this is a small village you are the  word or just thing I've ever seen  nobody's asked and it's small-minded as  well but small also means safe  we've come to my father  Collins the light  look a girl who said that  ello but you can talk hello course it's  all the other doesn't how lovely to make  your acquaintance  what does he do a trick that's when the  last petal for the mast our new men's a  beast forever and we become an truth  what is he doing  come out of here  you have to help me you have to stand if  she is the one will break the spell you  must finally learn to love so duster  have you really read every one of these  books somewhere in Greek who as it can  be  [Music]  [Music]  I've used to take your father's please  comments the light